Sometimes, knitters make things
harder than they need to be.
Here are two fast and easy
ways to increase stitches.
Just pull a new needle into work.
First,
if you pull a new needle on the carriage
side of the knitting,
you'll form a loop on the edge.
This is great if you
want a decorative edge.
I've even seen seams joined this way.
This technique is also used
to create a cast-on rag.
The loops make rehanging the rag
quick and easy for fast cast-ons.
To eliminate the loops,
just pull a new needle into work
on the opposite side of the carriage.
The edge is neat and clean,
and you'll speed through any
shaping that has increases.
But neatly seaming this
edge can be problematic.
You might want to consider a different
technique, one that creates a plain
stitch along the edge for seaming.
The Knit It Now tutorial,
Basic Increasing and Decreasing,
shows you some more increasing options.
Thanks for watching.
Now repeat after me.
Keep it simple,
and your knitting productivity will soar.
Subscribers
to the Knit It Now Learning Library have
full access to hundreds of tutorials on
various subjects at various skill levels.
Please treat yourself to a subscription
and join our community of knitters.
Happy knitting.